hallo mein name ist luca und ich bin an
meine arme können auf jeden fall noch
ein bisschen aufgepumpt werden deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ich spiele heute
das spiel das sperrgebiet duisberg bett
wie wird es ausgesprochen
das hier sind wir in dem spiel der sieht
auf jeden fall genau so aus wie ich das
ganze heißt judith beck duschbad wie
auch immer das ausgesprochen wird
workout zwei wir klingauf start gehen
und schauen was uns hier erwartet
objectives increase um es geht zu heck
und be popular ort geschickt
jetzt hat einmal und die endlich rein
houellebecq in slate okay wir bezahlen
einfach mal die partnerschaft und gehen
jetzt direkt ins gym trainiert
ich will wenn ich die ansprüche sagt die
wahrscheinlich ich bin ag das heißt die
erstmal hier zu trainieren
und schon gar nicht auf meinem handy
wird mir geratene formel angezeigt und
zwar wenig selbstbewusstsein kriege soll
ich mein vater anrufen und dann kriege
ich geld ok alter hier sind nur so neiße
chicks überall aber ich will die nicht
ansprechen weil die wollen jetzt erst
mal schön ein paar hanteln girls machen
damit ich hier schön den beats auf jeden
fall zwei prozent messen mein handy
sagte ich habe vier prozent 10 prozent
zweck und 0% popularity das müssen wir
ändern wo mein gott freunde ich sehe
gerade dass es hier anscheinend schied
gibt die ich irgendwie einlösen kann
wollt ihr irgendwann mal zweiten teil
davon werde ich jetzt mal versuchen das
ganze ein bisschen zu schaffen und im
nächsten teil dann irgendwie mit schied
ans ziel zu kommen wir gehen jetzt mal
schönen de shop und schauen uns hier an
was wir da gibt es ganz schön viel ich
klicke einfach auf ad franz und hier ein
paar leute hinzuzufügen die ich dann
irgendwie hab ich jetzt freunde meine
popularity ist auf vier prozent
gestiegen
das heißt wenn jetzt also 4 prozent aber
ich muss auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen mehr pumpen um einem netz
aufzubauen
so messe erst mal schön protein shakes
zu nehmen damit ich hier
auch hier wurde hat gesagt dass ich dem
minister habe damit die schneller als
aufbauen kann das heißt während ich den
jetzt trinke muss ich jetzt wohl ganz
viel trainieren damit ich irgendwie
meine märz schneller auf bauer kommt
schnell das muss ich auch mitnehmen hier
mit den teams darunter die messe schon
bei acht prozent und wir müssen jetzt
kommen mit dem bus wieder irgendwas ich
rufe jetzt einfach mal meinen dad an
weil er am 1 11 als team jetzt bei 100
prozent ist das heißt vielleicht gibt er
mir geld 405 da ich 405 habe gehe ich
jetzt erstmal hier in den turbo training
acht hennings ich dachte
trainingssession solche als erstmal hier
noch sonderen komischen drink und macht
dabei jetzt noch ein paar übungen damit
ich noch so ein bisschen meinen sie
durch junge du musst es schaffe
freilich wäre jetzt einfach mal wagen
und jetzt irgendwie diese lady hier
ansprechen heißt we can help you like
und dead erstmal gönne ich mir hier den
schönen cap ärgerlich dass auch gerade
habe ich habe mich jetzt zwei stunden so
ein bisschen mit dieser tanzer
unterhalten und sie jetzt so aus ich
weiß noch nicht ich durch mein handy da
unten so komisch stecken habe meinen
servers team gerade beim höchsten level
spreche ich sie jetzt einfach mal an und
ich brauche 20 ms und 5 prozent
popularity mit der hier was starten zu
können
das kriegen wir jetzt aber hin dann
mache ich hier noch schön die 18 die
ansprechen
da ich jetzt bei 20 prozent märz
angekommen bin werde ich jetzt noch eben
schnell bei der social sache hier ein
paar freunde eben hätten und dann
vielleicht noch mal ich kann mein status
gar nicht updaten meine popularity is
auf 7 prozent gestiegen
das heißt wir sprechen jetzt die tante
da an bord mit mehr flexibilität carl
xvi
das war das was sich dadurch jetzt
erreicht habe ist dass ich da oben in
denen das war es mit diesem video ich
bin relativ enttäuscht jetzt gerade vom
ende wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen und wenn
ihr einen nächsten